and that there is nothing else besides
that there is no underlying concrete
reality
that your mathematics is describing
it suffices to just dispense with it you
don't need that concrete reality
all is mathematics it is not the
mathematics we currently have in our
textbooks
but that's fine because our textbooks
themselves are simply
some of the um
characteristics the projection operators
of the quality and quantum physics
of the wave function of the universe
um
have you ever heard the phrase
we shouldn't mistake the map for the
territory
i don't believe i've heard the phrase
yes or it's actually it's sometimes the
map and the territory don't miss it
don't mistake them right that's right
what did i say
you said the math and the charity no no
i meant the map if i i misspoke yeah the
map of the territory because in that
case there's stuff that's not that's um
not in the
uh map that is in the territory and you
can um experimentally ascertain that
this point is that um the map that we
currently have
is not the ultimate map
but the ultimate map so to speak the oor
map
has in it this is almost like a broad
hazy and kind of a
image that's coming to the fore here
it's got in it as a little small part of
it some people looking at their own
little cartoon maps
of the full map
and that is all that the territory is
the territory is itself a map
we have a map which should not be
mistaken for the map that is the
territory
how do we know
how do we know that all is math
we don't i remember i was very very
careful the way to phrase this that one
perspective
which is consistent and simple
it doesn't invoke unseens
as since going back to kant at least
western philosophy has been prone to
doing
or plato for that matter with his
platonic ideals
it doesn't invoke all those unscenes
because it's pointing out
that ultimately
we are it's by flipping the perspective
to say that we
are phenomenal generated by it
rather than it is something external to
us that we are trying to understand
it's a flip of the perspective you start
with the it
and we are manifestations of it
projection operators as they call in
physics of those pieces of the it
rather than starting from ourselves and
almost a copernican and pre-copernic pre
copernican view of the earth as the
center we are the center trying to infer
the
outside territory no
we are ourselves just one small little
map in this much bigger map
and from that perspective you don't need
anything outside and everything is
explained all of these conundrums
you know no free lunch how does that
allow me to even get going
um yep you're correct little boy that no
free lunch doesn't allow you personally
to get going
but that doesn't change the fact that
here is a
way that
here is a i'm not even sure what you
would call it it's not saying it's a
reality it's not saying it's hypothesis
it's just a
[Music]
edifice of
interrelated explanatory phenomena of
mathematics
um which we don't even currently have
but
um which would actually
do a jiu jitsu move of all of our
philosophical conundrums
by simply saying that they are what come
up in the neurobiology of these
particular little systems that are being
generated as part of the solution to the
schrodinger equation when they try to
look outward at things outside of
themselves
sir how would you respond to my thought
which is it sounds like
we have quantities and then we say well
all that exists are these quantities and
not everything is quantitative however
it seems to that's what i mean when i
say that sorry that's my that's my
rendition of all is math
however it seems like there are large
classes of our experience which are
qualitative that don't lend themselves
at least not readily to quantity and to
me it sounds like a large statement to
say all of what we think of as
qualitative so anger the sight and the
experience of red and blue etc so you're
talking about qualia
yeah yeah not everything lends itself to
a quantitative analysis okay but are you
specifically talking about like chalmers
and these people their notion of what
they call qualia
sure
so i
view
that
conundrum is ultimately
ultimately vacuous we think that we feel
something i mean famously dan danett had
a great put down of the
people what does it feel like to be a um
hummingbird i think it was um that very
famous paper
um uh then it eviscerates it but um
ultimately
the question what is it
i don't see if there's any room for that
question any more than there's any room
for our belief for one hemisphere's
belief that's in control of the other
one
that belief is
wrong it is demonstrably wrong
neurobiology
can presumably in some future
incarnation
um explain why that hemisphere would
come to that conclusion after first
neurobiology has to even
figure out what it means to say that a
particular piece of
brain tissue is coming to a conclusion
or not
but it is wrong it is
got nothing to do with reality
that qualitative experience of that
hemisphere being controlled
no it's not
and but we can now expect this future
incarnation of neurobiology would be
able to explain all aspects
whatever question you might ask
of that subjective experience it would
be able to provide the answer
that there's not necessarily any room
for anything else
um
you said this has yet to be demonstrated
we just see you see this as reasonable
yes neurobiology has not done this
by a long shot um but i'm just saying
that what's consistent
with everything that we now know with
everything that we can think
of
would be consistent with map it's it's i
find it
let me tell you my thoughts quickly i'm
sorry to interject
when it comes to neurobiology and then
we have neural correlates of certain
qualitative experiences and then you can
say those correlates are quantitative so
we found an association between the
quantitative and the qualitative so
therefore the qualitative ultimately
reduces to the quantitative those
ultimately rely on many many many many
many reports of subjective experiences
so for example i'll have to tell you
maybe 50 times
i'm thinking of my mother before you can
find the mother
neuron if such a pattern exists but you
get what i'm saying we can pretend that
it does
so that means that it relies so heavily
on the subjective experience and
repeated subjective experiences that
don't replicate between brains so you'll
have to take it so so it varies between
individuals
and then
um my
i wouldn't even say these are claims my
statements do not have to do with
current neurobiology
or even necessary that neurobiology will
get there
it's much more the following
it's a challenge
to you
if in fact
there is something inherent
about the subjective
that
would not be reducible to
mathematical properties
given especially in light of the ben
libit experiments
the split blade and all the other
related
zombie within kind of phenomena
how could one even speak about it
without
reducing it to being a
mathematical thing what is even it
how can we even say anything
like we have a discussion
[Music]
with unless it's going to be defined
precisely and i don't know how to define
something precisely
without defining it precisely it's
it's a challenge how do you
other than sitting around rather than
having an aesthetic experience
which we can have
how do we actually engage in it in a
reasoning manner
without actually giving
it a definition that can be reasoned
about
and i don't know how to do and i don't i
just view mathematics as essentially
the body of all that we can
or reasoning that we can do
i don't i don't see what else it could
be how we could even have a discussion
about it
let's have fun here when you're saying
that you don't know how we can speak
unless we define our words precisely
well
well well it seems as though people have
gotten by for
thousands of years without the invention
of mathematics
or formal systems et cetera and and
they've had some communication and then
when it comes to well
no no but say i'm not saying
you and i can speak about viewing art
for example right now you've got a
guitar back there
i presume that you play
um
i don't wish i could but i i could
imagine that we could have an
interaction concerning music and if
in a different life um
where those particular regrets returning
to a previous theme
did not exist to me i might be able to
have some facility on and we could um do
it we could jam together
um or whatnot
um
that would be us communicating it would
all be legitimate it would be valid it's
a different form of communicating from
when we are trying to ascertain
jointly
using
reasoning processes
something concerning
i don't i wouldn't even use the word
existence because that by itself is a
fraud exercise but so it's a different
it's a different realm of discourse you
and i can very definitely
talk about what does it feel like
to experience beautiful music
what does it feel like to i mean red is
a simple minded one but to experience
beautiful art
i have often described how to me
uh i have been ambushed in my life by
paintings
um turn a corner in a gallery or a
museum and literally the phrase that
keeps coming to my mind i keep repeating
is i'm being ambushed i'm just knocked
flat
i'm stunned by it
it's a physical reaction by that by that
actual painting um to give you simple
examples things like monets and van gaal
because it's so beautiful that you're in
awe
in particular i never particularly
appreciate cezanne and so when i first
saw one in the flesh
then it ambushed me because there's so
many details of it that just don't
reproduce well when you read about a
cezanne piece small sandwich
simon sent i think it was
um
in the art books
it's all intellectual that he had this
effect on art history and so on and so
forth okay so you can read it like that
but then when i saw it
wow
i was knocked out of my socks and more
generally i can talk with you or anybody
else about how for me to actually judge
a painting the way that i judge it the
process i go through
is what can it teach me
if i myself were trying to redo that
painting and try to change some things
would i actually learn no wait you can't
do that
because of these aspects that you
weren't even sensitive to
does it have its own three-dimensional
reality that painting or is it just a
flat caricature
i don't mean necessarily a sense of
perspective i mean does it
exist i understand
um so we can have that discussion
um does that have anything to do with
furniture's equation
well i mean you know ultimately if you
want to flip things around and yeah sure
david you can have a different set of
discussions
where you're saying that these aesthetic
experiences in your head are just
neurobiology and so
sure you can and if you want to go off
and do it but that's a different
conversation we're having from talking
about that art piece ambushing me it's
irrelevant to talk about in terms of
schrodinger's equation sure yes but who
cares that's got nothing to do with the
actual discussion we're having
about what art pieces have that they can
teach you
conversely though
if i am instead in a different mood i've
woken up on a different side of the bed
and i'm discussing
philosophy
formal reasoning
what is the ultimate nature of reality
then
all the other stuff about being ambushed
it just the question gets reduced to
is all of that in theory at least
explainable or is there something there
that is not even in theory explainable
as being a
meta as an epi phenomenon an effect of
mathematical schrodinger's equation
it's a completely different way of of
engaging with
the same subject to me
and what i'm saying is that when i'm
over there wearing my metaphysics hat
if i'm just going to push metaphysics to
be what i
personally david walport i'm interested
in
and it's i can
i just don't even understand what else
there could be
besides mathematics and then aesthetics
i don't see that there's
i i don't see how we can be doing
reasoning reasoning rigid
iron cloud we know that with the the
things that as in class you can come up
with
given um all this stuff about noise and
deterministic reasoning
um
uh the deductive reasoning but how we
can actually come to any kinds of
conclusions
if we're not
using
logic let me say that second order logic
i mean that's part of mathematics
second order logic is part of
mathematics and i don't see how we can
if we can't even define the terms
in something like what is called in um
uh mathematical logic a language
where you've got an associated um set of
axioms and so on and so forth i don't
even see how we can be speaking about it
in those terms
i don't see what philosophy can be if
it's not that
i see when were talking about how some
of these philosophical claims are
volutinous they're bleary they're opaque
dubious you don't know what the heck it
means because there's they're speaking
ambiguously
and then you're saying well i don't know
what it means
i understand what mathematics would mean
if mathematics was fundamental for me
please help clarify for me what the heck
does that mean because to me that's just
equally i can understand the statement
that mathematics describes what we've
seen so far but then to say that
mathematics is what we've seen so far i
don't understand what that is is what is
the mathematics and then when we say
it's a rule what is a rule we can play
that game so can you help me understand
the ontology
um
this is the
so first of all assuming that we're not
worrying here about things like girls in
completeness serum or the other things
about math eating its own tail sure um
um we're not trying to do for example
press burger arithmetic which would
allow you to suit to avoid
girdles that could be the same or
anything um
it's
that's one of the things that i find so
a deep
flaw or attribute to me
is that
the more i can be
[Music]
smashed on my ass by the universe
realizing that i have been misconstruing
my limitations
for being those of the universe
the more i feel i'm making progress the
more i actu that's my aesthetic
acme
i don't think i can answer your question
and that's to me
and i understand your question and feel
your question
and the fact that i cannot answer it to
me
is a
[Music]
beautiful stunning illustration of the
fact that the
deficiency is in me
it's a feature not a bug
it's a feature not a bug